back at headquarters the wildlife
troopers receive another report of a
dead moose this one floating in a lake
the Moose is not in an area where you
normally find a dead moose which is
usually in shallow water on the side of
the lake it's actually floating in deep
water which gives us concern that this
moose has probably been shot it was
probably shoddy illegally it was
probably shot while it was swimming
killing a moose while it's swimming is
lieutenant the crime of wanton waste
comes with a mandatory jail sentence and
isn't something the wildlife troopers
take lightly I always take it they came
animal
is a big deal and something that bothers
me from a legal standpoint in from you
know just a personal standpoint that's a
white family eats
we usually utilize the resource and it's
just it goes everything
against everything that we stand for
when somebody just shoot but it it
leaves a kind of a popular destination
so somebody saw something somebody
either saw an airplane it was parked
there or once we have names we can start
talking to the hunters find out what
kind of rifles they shoots are putting
things together from there unfortunately
the dead moose is still a ways off
ashore and without a floatplane
there's nothing Quist can do at this
point except look
he returns to Fairbanks and informs
which a Nadal key with little to go on
doll key knows cases like these can take
months to unravel so we'll put the word
out we'll see if we can find out who's
out in that area or who may have seen
something out there possibly develop
some leads on an airplane or persons in
the area and then we'll go from there
that slug can make a little difference
down the road when we identify a
possible suspect because we can match it
up and I'll call it a Moo Society we can
match it up from that moose aside to the
person that actually pulled the trigger